All right.
Let us begin please.
We're going to get started to
stay on track for this morning.
Don't forget, of course, that we have
this exciting event next Tuesday,
which is our second test. Uh,
there will be, yeah, I know.
Yeah. Curb your enthusiasm. Uh,
there will be a review section for that.
Indeed,
three of them next Monday
night as we did last time,
there'll be in room two oh seven
of WL h again this Monday seven,
eight and nine respectively
and yours truly will be there.
Uh, we'll also have Monday afternoon
if you want the individual help,
you can come to my office and one of
the TA's will be covering a run of about
four or five hours there Monday afternoon,
probably starting around one o'clock.
And of course I'll be sending you a prep
sheet on this so that you will know how
to prepare for this test just as
we prepared for the last test.
If the test itself will be very
similar to the first test, except we,
when we get to the the listening pieces,
then we will not be so much concentrating
on individual isolated aspects of
melody, rhythm and harmony.
But these broader questions
of form, what is the form?
Where are we in the form? That's, that's
the essence of the assignment there.
Uh, we're working here with
form and it's very important.
It brings,
I think,
my guess is in all of the listening that
you've been doing pop music, classical,
whatever it is, how many, when you
were listening ever thought about form?
Do you ever think about even if you, okay,
one person I see ray raise their hand,
Robert or two maybe and maybe, and maybe
Roger raises his hand, but not too,
too enthusiastically. Uh, yeah.
It's a kind of thing that you could do
a lot of playing, listening to music.
You could, you could take, uh,
as my 17 year old may be 17 year old,
maybe 12,
13 years of cello.
And I could ask him what form do we have,
where are we in the form?
And he wouldn't really know because he
hasn't been exposed to that sort of thing.
Well, it does help us. It's a
whole dimension of listening
that we can plug into,
whether it's pop music and you're dealing
with verse and chorus and bridge or
even as we'll see today Ostinato and
in pop music we're in classical music.
You plug in the for now,
what are the six forms that we
are going to be plugging in here?
Hm.
Somebody run this through our checklist,
Roger and get us started please.
Oh yeah, you can say one and then,
then you pass the baton. Okay,
so not a leg or the most difficult.
The biggest one we spent the most
time with that. What else, Chris?
Phew. We spent a lot of time with that.
Fairly difficult. Daniel Rondo. Uh,
a little bit easier in a sense
that you've got this one theme,
that kind of bludgeon Jude.
If you get a theme,
then you get something else and that
theme comes back and then probably
something else yet again.
Then the theme comes back
and then something goes again
again and then and so on.
So you get the object and
then a lot of contrast,
but the object keeps coming back.
What else have we mentioned?
Uh, Chelsea. I'm sorry.
Turn. Reform. Yeah,
that may be, that may be the easier it's
going to have to just the a B a idea.
Uh, and we're missing one I
think. Yeah. Theme and variations.
Your name please. I'm sorry,
Kristen. Okay. Thanks very much,
Kristen. Um, so, uh, theme and
variations is, is the last one.
When you go to a concert, sometimes
you can pick up the program. Uh,
and here is a cover for a program that's
going to serve as the makeup for our,
uh,
the makeup concert for our class.
It's next Saturday,
a week from Saturday.
Jonathan Edwards Orchestra is going to
be performing at Battelle and there'll be
doing the Beethoven Eight symphony,
the Beethoven Eighth Symphony.
And when you go there,
uh,
you're going to have four movements
and that Beethoven Eight symphony,
what's a good guess as to what form the
first movement is going to be in to,
not all I got. Okay, so not
allegro second movement. Wow.
It could be in a number
of different forms.
What's a good guest for what the full
form of the third movement will be?
Ternary form. It's going to be some
kind of menu at or perhaps scared.
So I think in this case scare Cho,
trio scared.
So that idea ternary form usually is the
third movement of these four movements,
symphony.
And then the last movement,
well we'll have to sort of come to terms
with that figure that one out on the
fly and that's what we'll be
doing on our, our uh, um, uh,
a test on Tuesday. Although it will
be a slow sort of lento fly there,
we'll be going through,
it's much more slowly than just one pass.
So sometimes when listening you've got
to hear the music and make some kind of
educated a determination as to what the
form is. And then you kind of, as I say,
drop this template of that particular
form down in your mind and then filtered
the music thereafter through that model.
Be it the model of Sonata Allegro or
the model of few or the model of Rondo.
You kind of hear the piece
in that form, uh, thereafter.
Questions about that?
All right. If not, let's,
let's proceed with one,
the final, uh, form today,
which is Ostinato. That's our sixth
form. We haven't been introduced to that.
We're going to do Austin Natto.
But before we get to that,
I want to recap one thing having to
do with a theme and variation for,
because it allows us to bring in some
of the other things that we had been
talking about. So it's a good
culminating listening experience.
And that is the finale of
Beethoven's Eroica symphony.
Anybody know why,
why it's called the Eroica symphony?
Who's the hero that's referenced
there? Caroline Napoleon, right?
So Beethoven was working on the symphony.
Napoleon was a hero.
Then he gets word from Paris.
Napoleon has had himself crown emperor,
he thinks, oh my God. Napoleon is just
a tyrant, like all the rest of them.
So he's furious and he scratches
out on his score. And I,
when you get to the Beethoven
chapter of Your Textbook, look there,
there's a photograph of the
cover of the Eroica symphony,
and you can see the big hole where
Beethoven with his knife, uh,
scratched out Napoleon's name.
And then later on he goes on to simply
identify that and symphony for a hero
symphony for a hero,
the Eroica symphony.
So that's what we mean
by that particular term.
The hero originally was to be Napoleon.
So when we finished this x exercise,
when you finish this course,
you will have actually been exposed to
a number of Beethoven symphonies were
talking about number three here.
We opened with number five, uh,
on the concert a week from Saturday.
You have Beethoven Eight,
and those of you that went
to the preceding country or
not barred from attending
the one on the 1st of November,
you too can get in the door there.
So you might want to go to that,
uh,
seven 30 in Battell chapel November
1st and the concert the other night,
we had Beethoven six.
So you will have been exposed to for
Beethoven symphonies here in this course.
And that that's pretty good for
beginning course. Great. All right,
so let's talk about the finale here and
it's based on, and it's kind of fun.
It's actually more complex than
we would ever do on a test,
but it's fun to work through it. It's
based on two themes based on two themes.
So this is a set of variations using
two themes. Beethoven liked to do this.
He did this actually,
he did this in the slow movement of,
yeah.
What's that? What's symphony is
that? Anybody remember? Yeah,
I was the Beethoven six that we had at
the concert the other night with the
woodwinds and all that.
Aw.
And so on.
Okay.
That was the second thing. It
was kind of the, the second, uh,
the be idea if you will, of
the, of the, um, uh, two teams.
So they're in the slow movement
of Beethoven's Sixth Symphony.
We had a double variation in what we
mean by double variation is simply that
there are two themes in play. So
here we have the two themes. One,
the way he's constructed
here is in the trouble.
Yattaw hot, hot, hot, uh, um, pop,
pop, pop, pop, pop, pop upon Pla.
That's the number one.
Here's steam number two,
bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
Palm,
pop, pop, pop.
Yeah,
bum.
So those are the two teams.
So let's listen to some of this.
It's going to start out with just
a little bit of a curtain raiser.
So I have a curtain raiser,
then one of the themes will come in.
Which one does Beethoven start with?
Up goes the curtain.
Repeat.
Continue.
Yeah.
Yep.
Okay.
Then stop it there.
So which team did he choose to work with
here at the outset? Anybody Know Daniel?
Yeah, the base. The pink. And how was
it being played? Was it was my pitch.
Cuddle Bom, Bom, Bom, bom.
So was the BC. All right.
So that's in instance, we'll
save, call that variation one.
Let's go on with variation two here.
Which team does he choose
to use at this point?
Repeat
and repeat.
Okay. So which team is he
using? Their one or two? Yeah.
If Kenny says two and it was
still the base theme, um,
and it was a little bit harder to hear
this time because it was being covered up
above by some counterpoints.
So we've got the theme,
we've got counterpoint against it.
Let's go on to variation number three.
We'll see what happens.
Which one here
going on
and repeat.
Okay,
so which name is type one or to sell to,
but he's moved it up
into the first violin,
moved it up higher and he's got more
sort of fast running counterpoint
counterpoint against it.
Let's go on to the next.
We got to get number one at some point,
right?
[inaudible]
let's stop it there. Let's go back to
that particular variation if you will.
Please. I think it's at one 54. Uh,
what was the solo instrument there
and how did he orchestrate this? Well,
the first statement of this first theme,
he assigned it to a solo instrument.
Then in the repeat, he had
the strings, take it over.
Then that solo instrument came back and
then on the repeat the strings took it
over again. So it's an interesting
use of orchestration here.
Let's listen to this variation again and
what is the solo instrument up on top?
[inaudible].
Okay, let's pause it there
just for a second. So what's
the Solo Instrument? Oh, Bo,
yes, there's an opo penetrating upon
hiring question out there, Roger.
Um, yeah, I wouldn't want to
to take that too far though.
This is sort of an isolated event here
where you do have a call and response and
it does happen just in this one variation,
but it's going to be limited
to this one variation.
Whereas Ian Bessie Smith Blues tune,
you would have that call and response
idea carried on throughout the entire
composition.
It's a good point though.
I hadn't thought I hadn't thought of
it in those terms, but that's exactly,
you got a call by the elbow
and then repeat of that
idea maybe elaborated by the
strings.
So here we are up here,
the Solo Obo and then we are going to
have the response now by the string.
So let's listen to that.
[inaudible] we're gonna
pause it here just for a second.
There was something interesting happens
when we were dealing with Sonata Allegro
form. We said that there were
four functional types and this,
it really isn't just limited
to a sonata allegro form.
There are functional types in all
kinds of music. When you go to a movie,
a cinema of film for example,
oftentimes at the end of the scene they
will have a fadeout and listened to the
fadeout. There's kind of transition
music in film music a lot of times.
Then maybe we get a new
faith, a new scene, and it's
very prominently displayed.
Well maybe we get Sigmadek and music
at that particular point. So the,
this idea of theme and transition,
even development can occur in all
different kinds of music and all different
kinds of context. But just to review
that idea, we have thematic music,
we have transitional music,
we have developmental music.
Uh, and again, it doesn't have to
be limited to Sonata Allegro form.
We saw developmental music in a
section of a f of the few called what?
Anybody remember what we
called that section of the,
of the few that was so developmental
Thaddeus, the episodes. So there we,
in the episode of the Fugue we have
developmental activity and we get ending
credential stuff virtually
in every kind of music.
So it's not limited just
to Sinatra labor force,
but question here is what does Beethoven
writing at this particular structure?
A particular point here we
are in theme and variations,
but I think we're referencing one of the
four functional types of music in this
next set section.
So what functional type is it?
Okay.
Okay, so what was it that we just
heard? What would you guess Daniel?
A transition. Yeah, he's just taking
it very simply from point a to point B,
d d little e t t t t t
t t t t t t t t t t pop,
pop, pop, pop. And maybe just
a little bit idea of a cadence.
Transitions you lead in with a couple of
final sounding courts there at the end.
So that's a transition and we've
moved and we've moved from from here,
a major key. What would you
imagine we're going to move to?
Okay,
a minor key and it's probably again,
although we, we don't hear it,
I don't hear it.
We don't hear it.
It's probably gonna be the relative
minor it because it's just simpler
structurally to operate that way. So let's
listen now to the next variation here,
but something very interesting happens.
He's referencing another four.
He's incorporating another form
in the composition as a variation.
So what is the other form now?
Stop it right there. So what
form is he referencing? Uh,
Michael? Yes. Got It right
today. Okay. A few. Yeah.
And we just,
one hearing was little,
it'd be hard to really know what
voice voices we're bringing it in.
But I'll just tell you generally what he
was doing there was starting up on the
top.
Okay.
And then,
and gradually coming down down in
terms of range, it was soprano, alto,
tenor, and then bass. And the
bass did something interesting,
which sort of reinforces a
point we had the other day,
the fugue subject that he's working with,
which by the way,
so he's kind of a varying that melody,
number one
kind of varying that nobody. Uh,
but when it gets to the base,
it does something interesting.
Hmm.
Why is that interesting?
Huh?
What,
what,
what process do we have at work there
that we talked about last time with regard
to few? Anybody remember?
Remember that, uh,
Daniel Inversion and I don't think I
made that point clearly enough the other
day,
but anytime you have,
oh,
you could have
going up the minor third and then down
the second you could go down a minor
third and then up a second.
So you're just turning the intervals and
it kind of a mirror image there. So, uh,
hear Beethoven uses a
little bit of of inversion.
So in the middle of this
demon variation movement,
he inserts a few and a few
be inserted inside the,
another form is called a few Gato fugato.
So here as the fourth,
I think fifth variation,
fifth variation of this last movement,
he inserts a few Gatto.
Let's skip if you would please then to
all the way up to about eight zero zero.
We're going to, I'll listen
to one, the final variation
here. And we, at this point,
we want to concentrate on the duration
of the melody. We were starting out,
yacht party.
Tell Tom Bom bom
one, two, one, two in that fashion,
which Beethoven doing here,
how much there? Yeah,
it's a long way to go.
Uh,
pause second.
So what's done here too is melody
to the duration within his melody.
It's now,
can you express it if we were calling it
bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
and then we go Paul,
Paul,
what's he doing? Well, come on.
I just hear a little small
little words. Okay. Somebody,
let's choose somebody who's pretty
confident in that person will yell it out.
Marcos, I'm sorry, I didn't hear that.
That's the psychological effect
of Ritardando slowing it down,
giving you a sense you're getting
to the end. But once again,
technically that's not
exactly what he's doing.
He's giving that effect by doing
something that is corridor,
right? He's changing the note values.
He's simply doubling the note values.
And when we do that in music,
we call that augmentation.
Sometimes when we get
to Hector barely owes,
we'll see diminution to give a
sense of urgency to the music.
You can chop them all in half.
Well here he's getting toward the end.
He wants his grand broad effect.
He's brought in the brasses it showtime.
Uh, so what does he do? He doubles all
of the note values in theme number one.
So let's continue please.
Okay. And then he sort of fades out
and adds a little Coda at that point.
But that's the way we
end the third sentence,
the Eroica symphony of Beethoven.
So it's an interesting piece because
it's got a full Gato in there.
It's got sections, it sound like
transition out of Sonata Allegro form.
And he's working with two themes.
Questions about that before we move on?
All right,
so let's put that behind us now and
go on to talk about Ostinato form.
Once again, we've been through this
many times, but what is an Ostinato?
Yeah, okay. I know it's embarrassing.
It's something that happens
again and again and again.
This is sort of obsessive compulsive
disorder applied to music. Okay.
Obsessive compulsive disorder
applied to music. The,
the most famous example
of this is probably the,
okay.
The,
the Balero of Maurice Ravel.
So we put that up on the board
here as our first Ostinato piece.
1928 piece in the 20th
century. Uh, it's, uh,
Ostinato in every way in the sense that
the melody keeps repeating over and over
again for 14 minutes. The, the rhythm
God,
God that keeps going for 14 minutes and
change it depending upon the tempo of
the conductor.
And when we did this,
remember you guys were
providing the beige harm,
bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
bom, Bom, bom.
That's all you do for 14
minutes and 30 seconds.
So every aspect of that melody,
rhythm and harmony is controlled
by this Ostinato procedure.
Uh, and in this example, as
mentioned from the 20th century,
but the heyday of Ostinato
form, uh, well really in,
in two,
in two periods in the history of music,
one in the Baroque period
and two right now, right now.
Because when you start
listening to your pop music,
go out there and listen to those base and,
and start charting those bases
and see how repetitious they are.
When Frederick Evans brought in that
piece of insync or whenever it was that he
brought in and I started
listening to that answer, my God,
he's got a descending Tetra cord
base Ostinato embedded in that,
and I'm sure Frederick didn't
sit there scratching. Oh yes,
there's my descending Tetra
court, chromatic descending
Tetra cord base there,
but it's in there. It's embedded
in so much of this popular music,
and that's kind of what we're
going to track here a little bit,
but we're going to start with the Baroque.
So we could start with WHO's,
who's the best or the, yeah, we could
even say the best composer of the Baroque.
Well,
Jay Ashbach js box.
So let's start with an Oregon piece of
box and will listen to an Austin auto
base. Generally speaking, in
music, when you get an Ostinato,
it's applied to the base.
It sets up a repeating harmony.
So that's what we got here.
So here's a Pasa, Kalia,
just a little bit of it by Bach,
uh,
[inaudible]
and you can see what he's doing
once he gets his base in there.
And it's a typical eight bar pattern.
It's odd how many of these Austin
that'll basis are in eight bar unit.
So it's an eight bar
pattern here with Bob.
Then all he does is keep throwing
over top of that rhythmic patterns and
slightly different melodic patterns
as well. But that base yacht,
he taught home,
partied hard on body
poem,
keeps churning away over and
over underneath in that piece.
For what instrument?
By Bach.
Okay.
Oregon. Big powerful pipe organ. That
wonderful, wonderful sale. All right,
so that's an, that's an
introduction to the Baso Ostinato,
the Ostinato Bass by Bob.
Let's turn to some music now of Henry
personal and we personal wasn't English
composer working in London at
the end of the 17th century.
He was employed by,
must have been James the second and then
I think William and Mary for a little
bit. Uh, so he wrote for the courts
and he also wrote for the theater.
And in one instance, it turned out
to be his most famous composition.
He wrote an opera for an all girls
boarding school in the London suburb of
Chelsea, I guess is now part of downtown
London. There's a famous soccer team,
Chelsea something, I don't
know, you see him on TV. Um, uh,
so there's Henry personal audit,
this all girl boarding school
and annually they put on a drama.
So it was kind of like the senior class
play in all of the roles were sung by
women,
except in this case one role was
sung by a male and that was the,
the role of Aeneas.
So we've got the famous
story of Dido and a niece a,
you've probably read it
in literature classes.
You've probably read parts of it
in Latin. Um, it's from book for,
and it used to be in a really
good secondary type education.
When you're doing Latin, you've had
maybe six or seven years of Latin,
you would read the, uh,
Virgil's Aeneid in the original Latin.
Anybody do that in your,
wow,
holy Schmoley math.
Latin is making a serious comeback
here because it's not easy.
It's not easy stuff. Uh, it's,
it's traditional classical Latin where
the syntax is radically different than
the medieval Latin or any kind of
modern, um, modern language. Okay, well,
good for you guys. So, uh,
uh, you, you know the story.
Somebody tell me the story
then. Michael, what's the story?
Okay, so I need us has to
leave for another country.
It happens to be what
country? Yeah, he's got it.
He's got to follow his destiny and go
off and found the city of Rome. Uh,
and in the vernacular having
ditched Dido back in Carthage,
uh, she's not happy about
this. Uh, she dies, uh, uh,
depending upon the theatrical version or
the original sheet there stabs herself,
falls on the burning funeral pyre or dies
of a broken heart. But this is opera.
So you know that at the end of
it, the Sopranos got a die, right?
This is the way opera die
operas in Di did. So, uh,
in what you could do a Violetta and
Traviata, you could do Tosca and Tosca.
We've even seen here,
the leap is toe at the
end of Wagner's Tristan.
He's older, dies after singing.
The lead is tote, expires there.
So it's a convention of opera.
And in this particular
opera we have a famous Aria,
it's called Dido's lament,
where she is lamenting the fact that
she has been abandoned by a Nia.
And it's interesting because it's built
on an Austin auto baseline and it's
built on an Ostinato bass line that
descends. And this is important
because it became a convention for Lemon.
So this is the baseline
for Dido's lament here.
Yours,
tea, tea, tea,
God,
hard ball,
Yardi, Todd, Todd,
ah, top, Ooh.
And it just keeps me recycling over and
over and over again. That's the Ostinato.
Uh, and then up above it we have the
limitation. When I am lead in Earth, me,
my wrongs create no trouble in my
breasts. Remember me, remember me,
but I'll forget my feet. So
that's what she's singing. Uh,
so let's listen to a bit a bit of this.
And before we do that,
we have the term on the board up there,
ground base,
all that is is the English term for Austin
auto based ground base Ostinato bass
the same thing. But it gives us a
sense at least at the base grounds,
it kind of holds together. It's the
foundation for the entire composition.
Uh, so let's listen. We'll start with
the ground base. Nice and loud here,
Linda please.
And then the singer will come in.
Uh
Aw.
Hey,
let's stop it there.
So that's how this plays out and that
base keeps cycling through the duration of
this particular Aria.
Listening to this recording gives us the
opportunity to think about approaches
to music.
This is a piece written at the end of the
17th century and actually with in this
particular recording,
they're playing this and singing in a
way that would be rather similar to the,
they would've done it in the 17th century.
They have reproductions of 17th century
instruments and the singer here is
trying to create a particular
approach vocally to the music.
So as we listen to this
recording one more time,
we're going to hear just a little bit more
of it and then we're going to, um, uh,
ask you to compare this
recording to another recording.
This would be the kind of thing
that a reviewer would do. So, um,
let's listen to a bit more
of, of this, uh, recording a,
we'll call it and then we'll move on.
Right.
Pause it there.
Now we're going to go onto recording be,
so what's the difference here in
approach terms of orchestra, everything.
Vote voice in.
Uh,
how does recording be
differ from recording a
Oh,
oh,
so we'll, maybe we'll pause it
there. What's your reaction to that?
How do those two differ
hands please,
Caroline.
Okay. First Singer had a much
more youthful approach, uh,
and you could see that as an attempt
to maybe a duplicate the performance
context of the original
performance in high school,
a girls' school there in
late 17th century London. Um,
more specifically, what about the
quality of that voice? Any thoughts?
Uh, Roger. Okay.
Now should we have the two recordings?
Which of the two had more
of a Bronto one or two,
two had a lot more of a broader.
So that's,
that's really the big difference here.
That one was a very well focused voice
with very little vibrato and maybe that's
what gave it this youthful appeal appeal.
It's almost like the voice of a choir
boy or choir girl for Heaven Sake.
So I'm of a pre adolescent child,
but intending to make
it very pure and very,
very clean and very well focused.
The second recording,
uh, what that might be a recording that
you would expect to hear performance you
would expect to hear where
maybe in a modern opera,
a seat. Oh, a theater or an opera hall.
A hall designed for opera where we've
got this huge expanse that we have to
fill. What about the orchestra? Um,
Frederick
repetition,
you mean higher in terms of pitch?
Frederick,
you have a very good year actually that's
true. I don't want to get into this,
but uh,
the first recording is pitched in
f sharp in the old baroque tuning.
They're trying to really be so
authentic pitch in the Baroque era,
which was actually lower than it is today.
We know that because their tuning
forks that survived in that period,
they got labeled on it a, you play that
a, and it turns out to be our g sharp.
So Aficionados of this
particular repertoire,
when they go to perform baroque music,
they're gonna use reproductions
of authentic instruments.
They're going to use non-VA Brado singing
and they're going to use the lower
pitch.
I didn't plan on getting into that,
but since you picked up on it a good
for you. Now we don't have to hear that.
And to be honest with you,
the only reason I remembered that was
I went to duplicate it before coming in
here today. I went to duplicate
those pitches on the piano,
so I'd be up to speed with
this and I realized, Jesus,
I'd have to do this in f sharp and
that's going to require some quick
transposition up here because I can do
it quickly. And Gee, we only two flats,
but f sharp. Well, I'm in sharp side. Got
there and I have to figure all this out.
So, um, but that is going on there.
That's an interesting development.
Anything else?
What about the tempo of the two?
Size of the orchestra always
determines to some degree the tempo.
I'm Oscar. Yeah. The,
the second recording was much slower.
You S I was intentionally trying to beat
it up here and it was a very labored
beat pattern.
It was much slower because they had many
more instruments or a lot more people
playing axiomatic.
The more people you have,
the longer it takes for sound to clear,
the slower your tempo we'll go.
Unless you have a maniacally tutorial
type of conductor that will really push
you. So it, it leads
to the more people, uh,
the slower the tempo is going to go.
So what we have here is a reproduction
of a attempt to reproduce authentic 17th
century performance as opposed to
a modern performance, big sale,
metropolitan opera type
of setup. All right, uh,
let's move on here.
One of the interesting aspect of this,
I discovered this raw
driving down Whitney Avenue.
This is true driving down Whitney Avenue.
One day,
I must've been fishing for 91.5 and my
FM dial and suddenly had a seizure or
something and it didn't quite make it.
And I was listening to Elton John. Okay.
Listening to Elton John and
uh, what did I hear? But the,
the, the craziest thing, what I
heard was this text. It's sad.
It's sad. It's a sad, sad situation.
And then I heard [inaudible]
totty the hardy poem.
I said, Whoa, wait a minute there.
That's the personal baseline.
Elton John has stolen the person
baseline arrest that man, no,
we don't do this because as we say,
these baselines are in the common domain.
As we have said before, you can't sue
anybody for the theft of a baseline.
And indeed it was all over the place
in the Baroque. This is a type of,
it became a kind of musical icon.
Anytime that audience would here,
they would think death or bad news.
Uh,
and actually we still do today. It doesn't
hit the road jack based on that same,
same kind of Austin Austin that obey.
Uh,
but in the baroque you could go back to
month severities, lament, Adela, nene far,
you could go to box
[inaudible] Zagon to whine.
Kvetch uh, you could go to the
crucifix. So the Bach B minor mass,
what could be more painful or a
dispiriting than a crucifixion? Uh,
so this was a Monica, it was a kind of
a kind of emblem of lemon [inaudible],
whether it's in person, whether it's in
Bach or whether it's in, in Elton John.
So when Elton John was to
take this and he used it,
not the beginning of this
piece, sorry, is the sad,
or sorry is the hardest word to say.
He didn't use it at the beginning.
He used it in the chorus. So here we
are in the chorus of Elton John's.
Uh, I think it's, sorry is the saddest
thing to say or something like that.
It is,
it's sad.
It's
always seems to mean Bob seems to be,
and then he goes on with the next verse.
Okay.
So that's just one example of a use of
that particular Austin. It would be,
we actually call that a limit base.
And any Mozart even did it.
And he wrote a Violin Sonata
on the occasion of his
mother's death and e minor.
And he has that thing just
going down the descending.
Basically it's this descending tetra
cord here that gets filled in chromatic
like all right,
so we've got that as an Austin auto base.
What's the most famous
Ostinato Bass of all time?
Baroque or modern pocket bell base.
Okay.
And we've got this thing
called the pocket Bell Canada.
Do you have the Xerox for today?
What's the pocket bell cannon?
Well we've worked a little bit with this,
I think it was listening exercise eat I
believe early on in the course where we
were trying to uh,
have you focused on changing harmonies
and these harmonies are just generated by
this repeating baseline. Um, there's a,
there's an irony with the pocket bell
cannon and that is that you never hear the
cannon in the pocket bell cannon.
Why is that the case?
It's because if you look,
he's got these three concentric lines,
the three staves up above,
all in the same register.
And when people record this, they
always do it with the same instrument,
usually just with the violin.
So we had the violins up above three
violins all playing in the same register.
You can't pick out the can and it just
sounds like this unfolding jumble.
It's very beautiful jumble. But it,
it, it's in distinctive in that sense.
Maybe if they work a straight at oboe,
flute and clarinet,
maybe we could hear the cannon better.
What we hear,
of course grinding away
underneath is the Ostinato Bass.
So let's listen to just a bit of this.
Um,
and I was struck the other day when I
went back and listen to this recording on
your cds,
they have put in this w uh,
something that's actually pocket bell
didn't, right when this starts out,
they just start with the,
what's that?
It's a descending major scale.
So they've just say, all right,
here's your basic tonality,
here's your total grid or whatever.
So let's listen to the bass start out.
Then we'll have this descending scale.
The pocket bell didn't,
right.
And then his cannon will start and
you can see how this works here.
I've indicated a gets repeated
as B comes in and, and so on.
It's pretty straight forward.
How the Canon,
okay,
here comes the scale now
and now the canon stars a one
second voice comes in.
First voice goes on to
present something new.
[inaudible]
sit here that we're going to pause
it here. It goes about four minutes.
It's very beautiful. It's lovely.
Lovely, lovely, lovely, lovely. Um,
but you know this base,
right? Right. Okay.
So there's our D let's all
sing it together. Ready? Sing.
Uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh,
uh,
okay. So once you get that
in your ear, you have a sense
it's really in there.
And did,
you may have heard that
many different times before.
Now lots of people made use of the
pocket belt cannon. And I know of,
of at least three and maybe four that
I've put up on the board up there.
And you may know of more,
Marcos sent me a you
tube clip of a comedian.
Maybe you guys have seen this.
Where's the comedian's name?
He was making sort of so sick of the
pocket bell cannon because every PC picks
up has got the baseline of
the pocket bell cannon in it.
W what comedian was that? It doesn't
matter. It doesn't matter. Okay. Um,
so those are my four.
Anybody else know where else they show up?
All right, well let's review, but
keeping the key. Oh, Thaddeus good.
Brittany Spears has the pocket bell
cannon. What a time to be alive. Wow.
All right. That is, go get that for me.
I need this one because this is gold.
Um, thank you very much. But so, but check
it. For example, one of the students,
Daniel in here, uh, it sent me, um, uh,
gave me and we talked about
it. Um, uh, let's go to that
one. Let's go to that one.
Uh, um, the itch, it would
be CD four, track two,
at about zero 20. Uh, he said, uh,
this may be a knockoff of
the pocket bell cannon.
It's called the Taco bell cannon.
So let's see if the Taco bell cannon is
in fact embedded in the Taco bell cannon
here.
The taco bell base.
Okay.
The pattern you were singing yes or no?
I mean, think yes. Raise your right hand.
Let me think. No, raise your left hand,
Huh?
Nope. It ain't the pocket bell.
Canada. Is it an Austin auto base? Yes,
it's an Austin auto base. Um, so,
uh, we could keep playing with that.
I could play you coolio blues
traveler, vitamin C, just for a laugh.
Let's do vitamin C, which is
CD a two track one. You've, uh,
uh, and I'm sorry about this, but
it's, it's too good to pass up. Okay.
So out you go.
Thanks for your [inaudible].
Okay.
Appropriately enough. It's
in the key of c Vitamin C, c
25.